defense secretary James Madison US
commanders in Afghanistan yesterday who
are fighting what is now considered to
be the longest war in American history
for residents of the region it means a
generation living under the shadow of
violence Charlie d'Agata has covered the
conflict there for the past decade he's
in Kabul where he spoke to some of the
wars survivors reassurance from defense
secretary mattis might be a hard sell
during a week that is seen yet another
spike in violence here as Afghans mourn
the dead from the recent explosions in
Kabul this is what a generation of
bombings and bloodshed does to a city
blast walls that go on forever we drove
across the Capitol to the scene of an
attack that shocked the world in 2016
from the outside the American University
looks like a supermax prison inside the
blast walls and razor wire the campus is
an oasis of calm but it was the target
of a Taliban rampage that lasted ten
hours killing 16 students faculty in
Police student Breanna Mousasi is still
haunted by that night I heard multiple
gunshots and then the explosion occurred
like it went dark and I couldn't see
anything I could not run because of the
polio on my right leg I could not run so
I was trapped a gunman's bullet tore
through her good leg he then came back
and shot her in the foot so I was there
for almost six hours pretending to be
dead I thought I would not make it and
that time I was missing my family they
were a big reason she vowed to return to
school when she recovered I had the
support of my family and I really wanted
to come back the joy I really wanted to
see the campus again after the attack
and go to the play place where I was
shot
and I I wanted to finish this degree
because because this degree was very
very important for me she did earn her
degree in May with honors after an
American trustee paid for her to have
medical treatment in Dallas she wants to
be a human rights lawyer and practice
here where she's needed most for CBS
this morning Saturday Charlie d'Agata
Kabul Afghanistan